Ladies and gentlemen, President, we are about to
open a process of reflection on the
future of the union. We say that we are going to
listen to the people who want to set
the course and do it in a way that is
closer to the citizens, but if there is something
that we are clear about, it is that nine  one in
ten European men and women think that
social Europe should be a priority,
in fact strengthening social Europe is not
so much a project for the future as one with
the past because in the last two
decades of the union it has allowed itself to be dominated
by a logic  neoliberal that has not been
accompanied by the planned social policies
and therefore in
November 2017 the European Union
proclaimed the European Pillar
of Social Rights in Gothenburg but we
have not yet been able to implement it and the
action plan that the
commission is now presenting is  the beginning of a strategy
in which we socialists are not going to
stop insisting commissioner nicolás
smith has made an effort in
political coordination  or for presenting an
ambitious proposal that includes some of
our demands but not all of them, that is why
we continue to insist and the
Portuguese presidency gives us the opportunity to
move forward with a clear agenda with a
key date, the social summit in Porto,
which will be a turning point for this plan
of action is a fundamental demand of
the socialists and democrats and it was part
of our electoral program in 2019 we
are not going to give up for two reasons because
there are injustices that have lasted a long
time such as precarious contracts
youth unemployment the wage gap
between men and women  but also
new risks for equity and
social justice such as the
climate emergency and climate change in
our model, therefore, without a doubt,
we need and have to give
absolute priority to the social agenda
because economic and social policy
were from the beginning  beginning of European integration
the two sides of the same
coin and will not be able to have  One success
is the economic project if
the social impact of these is not taken into account
and we will not have a fair society
as long as inequality between
men and women continues, that is why our
objectives must be
more closely linked to the action plan with the
un sustainable development goals what worries me most about this plan
is the lack of goals and proposals
for quality employment and it only
mentions decent work in development
trade neighborhood policies
and what about quality work
of European men and women
in 2019 there were 91 million
people at risk of poverty and these
are data from 2019 without taking into account
the impact of the pandemic therefore we
need to be more ambitious with the
child guarantee governments must
commit to  social progress plans
with clear and applicable objectives
is the only way to turn our
declarations into
concrete proposals and  quantifiable
encouraged the Portuguese presidency to be
ambitious and I offer you the full
cooperation of my political group I
hope the rest of us continue on the same path
thank you very much